All right. Wonderful.
Steven Gerbsman, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
My pleasure.
Really, really great to have you.
With 51 years of experience in crisis management,
as an investor, angel investor as well,
and really understanding how
to maximize the value of enterprises.
I'm so excited to learn with you
exactly what is crisis management.
And I'd love to spend the next
20 minutes getting to know you better
and gaining some insight that hopefully
one day as a seasoned entrepreneur,
I will have to confront a lot
of the lessons that you've already learned.
So, let's dig in. Who are you, Steven?
So, let me give you a little brief background.
My career started with the IBM Corporation.
I was president of four operating divisions
of a company called ITEL Corporation
in San Francisco,
which is in the computer ... business.
In the 80s and 90s,
I was a hands-on crisis turnaround CEO
being dropped in by equity or senior lenders.
Around 2000 when the internet -
What does that mean? Wait.
Steven, what does that mean
an interim CEO crisis turnaround?
Companies, let me turn it around.
Companies fail
and companies succeed
for different reasons.
Companies fail for three reasons:
lack of control,
preservation, and forecasting of cash.
Lack of control,
And lack of control,
preservation, and forecasting of cash.
It's all about cash.
You have management issues.
You can have market issues.
You can have gross margin issues.
You can have competition.
You can have FDA issues.
Doesn't matter.
If you have enough cash,
you can get through the process.
And boards of directors or senior lenders
focus on what happens in companies.
But let me take it to 19, around the 2000s
and I'll talk about,
because I think this is a thread here.
When the internet blew up,
we observed
that there were no hard assets.
It was intellectual property.
You had software,
you had medical device,
you had life science,
you had mobile, you had fuel cell
later on, you had solar.
So, there was a whole new industry
that grew up where your normal M&A process
really wasn't viable.
So, we got involved around 2000
with companies that had anywhere between
10 to 200 million dollars invested.
Okay.
And these companies,
again, something happened,
but it all revolved
around amount out of cash.
They were either senior lender companies or
they were venture private equity companies.
To the extent that what they needed to do
was find a way to go forward.
So, if the board or the bank
decided not to continue to invest,
which is all about cash,
what happens then?
So, you gotta maximize value
and relationship to the market.
So, we created a process called
the Date-Certain M&A Process
where we go to market in six weeks,
we maximize the value
of the intellectual property and assets.
We've done 109 deals.
109?
109 deals.
And to the extent that
we were able to save jobs,
save intellectual property that -
Steven I wanna just summarize
to make sure that I understood this correctly.
What you're saying is
if you have a company,
it has investments of historically
of 10 to 200 million.
Now, they've reached a point where
the investors, current or new,
are not interested in continuing along.
The company is now in a problem
because it's running out of cash.
It has assets.
It has intellectual property.
It has value.
But now you're coming in
and you're saying,
"I want to help you maximize this value.
I'm gonna come in for six weeks
in and out
and I'm gonna maximize
the value of the assets you have
and I'm gonna try to save
as much as I can
of the value of your company"
Right?
I'm gonna try to save as much as I can
for the value for the stakeholders.
For the stakeholders.
Stakeholders are equity
creditors, senior lenders,
investors, all of the above. So basically -
Are employees’ stakeholders?
I would call employees stakeholders.
And when you go forward,
part of the objective
is it's hard for investment banks
to do these type of deals
because they get into
what I call M&A nirvana.
They get in reps of warranty issues.
You can go on forever.
You get letters of intent.
And that isn't the real world.
So, we go to customers, competitors,
strategics, VCs for their portfolio companies,
senior lenders.
We're branded worldwide.
We just did a deal in Israel.
We've done a couple deals in China,
Australia, obviously the US.
And the message is
the board has made a strategic decision.
They wanna go forward
and try to monetize and maximize value.
And why did the board do this?
Basically, they have a fiduciary responsibility
to all those stakeholders and creditors.
Right.
And to the extent, part of the challenge is,
there has to be enough money
in the company to run a process.
To pay us, to pay the employees,
to keep things going, etc.
What's happened over the years
after the debacle in '07 to '09 if you will,
is that senior lenders who represent
probably about 30% of our deals
that they're involved in,
made sure that they put covenants in
that there was enough cash to maintain
the operation to go forward.
But basically, the board has said,
"I wanna decide what we do to go forward.
We're not gonna put any more cash in.
We don't wanna do a hard shutdown.
We want to meet our fiduciary responsibilities."
So, we're an independent third party
that's able to go to the market,
find out what's going on,
and we basically send out a sales letter.
All due diligence is done
prior to the bid date.
We send out an asset purchase agreement.
We require a deposit.
Highest bid that conforms
to the asset purchase agreement wins.
Bids come in to me
so it's a closed process.
We've changed the dynamics
of power and control
where the bank is sitting their, investment bank,
and holding the company off to an LOI
or whatever one on one.
It's anybody can bid.
Highest bid wins,
and we go back and hondle on price
and all that stuff at the end.
And the company can either
accept or reject the deal.
Now the perception of value is always
in the eyes of the beholder.
And value is the market.
The market will determine value
because it isn't what people pay for it,
it's what people,
what it costs to get to the next step.
So, as I said, we've done 109 deals
very credible in that market, et cetera.
But let me give you some observations that -
By the way,
just to make sure I understand,
when you come into the picture,
it is understood by all parties
that this company is going to be
either merged or acquired.
Is that correct?
Well, it is understood
that we're gonna do
an asset sale
meaning the company
without its liabilities.
Meaning that the acquirer
can decide which people they want.
In all cases, the value of the IP and assets
or the company without its liabilities
is really related to the quality
and availability of the key intellectual capital,
which are the people.
And it really isn't the CEO,
really isn't the CFO,
it's the IP technology people.
The people who really work in these areas
that make sense.
The VP R&D, those roles are
When you invest in a $200 million,
half of our deals have been
in the medical device life science area.
All right.
Basically because
they bring the most return
and they can have a CE mark,
which is approval of Europe.
They can be in some form of FDA, etc.
But I want to take you to one area
that you sort of alluded to.
When we talk about
why companies fail
and why companies succeed
and young entrepreneurs,
the biggest frustration and challenge
for myself and my partners,
we're all like CEOs,
is that the board of directors
doesn't hold the CEO responsible
and accountable enough.
All right. I'm ready for this now. Yeah.
All right.
So you have venture capital,
you have senior lenders,
you have private equity.
A lot going on. When things are going well,
you're the CEO
you're king of the hill.
If you haven't been through a down cycle,
you don't know what to do.
CEOs will shut down.
They won't communicate.
We've been in situations where
everybody in the company
knows what's going on,
but the CEO is concerned
about communicating that,
which is the worst thing you can do.
Of course.
It's all about leadership,
motivation, morale,
communicate, communicate, communicate.
You tell people the truth
and it will free your soul,
but make it a lot easier
so you don't bulls**t anybody.
How often do CEOs are not
completely open with their board?
How many of the cases would you think?
Well, it isn't a matter of not
being open with the board.
It's a matter of either the board
not forcing issues sooner than later
because they see something's happening
and they're working on a leap of faith.
Or the CEO doesn't communicate sometimes -
But is this a common thing?
Is this a common phenomenon?
I would say, here's what's common.
What's common is at least 30 to 40%
of companies that we get into,
the CEOs have not been experienced enough
to know what to do. In other situations
they've been through it a couple of times.
You know, in cases it's a badge of honor
if you have a company doesn't make it
because you know what's going on and
you do the best you can.
But the real issue comes down to
when you get in crisis mode.
You need to communicate
to your employees,
to the creditors,
to your stakeholders,
to the senior lender,
to your vendors, to the market.
Okay.
And one of the issues that you find
if you are important to these people
and you're actually delivering product
with your intellectual property,
it's hard for them to go away.
So, you get creditors to support you
and they want to see something happen.
Right.
So, when we use the term,
"maximize the value of the intellectual
property and assets"
we're trying to find a home
that will take it to the next level.
Now, here's the waterfall.
The waterfall is when we do a deal,
then we get paid,
the lawyers get paid,
and management gets paid.
But the real people that come after that
are the secured creditors,
which is the lender.
And then you've got the unsecured creditors,
which are the creditors, the payables.
Equity rarely gets paid off in these deals.
But the real, the issue that you're doing is
you're meeting your fiduciary,
I used that word a number of times,
and if you're gonna ask me about
three words, I'm gonna give
you the three words right now:
Ethics, Integrity and Leadership.
Okay.
You go through life,
you don't sell your soul,
you tell people the truth,
and you get through it.
The hardest thing to do,
when we get involved,
my partners and I can go into
any company and in three days,
tell you what's going on.
And here's the profile.
If we sit down and a CEO doesn't let us talk
or we have a meeting with the CFO,
the CTO, the CMO, all the key executives,
and all that the CEO does
is tell us what's going on.
I know we got a problem
because the strong CEO is gonna say,
"CFO, tell me what's happened.
CTO, tell me what's happened.
CMO, tell me what's happening."
And you try to work the problem
in an open environment.
But again, it's not necessarily,
it's experience.
I mean, how old are you right now?
24.
God bless you.
You're the future and you give us hope.
Thank you very much.
Now, run your company at 27
but unless you've never been through it. So -
That's what I wanna know, Steven.
So, now it's time for some selfish request
because I want some advice from you.
I'm gonna run a company.
I'm very excited for that.
I hope I get to a point where my company
is big enough and strong enough.
And you know what,
I hope that we're gonna have to fight
some hurdles because I wanna learn
and I wanna experience.
What do I need
to keep in mind from day zero?
I don't wanna reach a crisis
and then ask you -
So, what you need to do from day zero
is the following, okay
One, you cannot lead if you haven't done.
Go make a sales call.
Call a vendor.
Go down to the manufacturing plant.
Meet the people.
Understand how to communicate to employees.
Close an order.
Talk to the senior lender.
Force people into a discipline
because it's all about respect,
but you don't get respect
until you really know what's going on.
The other thing is,
I told you the three
reasons why companies fail.
Start with putting in a discipline,
a bottoms up, go forward cash flow.
Not top down.
You see all these great spreadsheets
and I look at them when I come in.
Too late.
I say "This doesn't mean anything to me"
I need to understand what we have
is cash in the bank
and on a weekly basis,
what I'm spending,
why and how,
and what creditors I can push off or not
because I need to preserve control
and forecast cash.
Now, you're a healthy company.
You just got 10 million bucks.
Okay. You're feeling good.
Your best business partner
is your chief financial officer.
He or she.
You hold them responsible
and accountable
and you need to understand
the numbers.
Many, many years ago,
when I became a division president
of one of the groups at ITEL corporation,
the CEO came in and said,
this is before we had real spreadsheets,
"I want you to run
your business model with your hand
so you know everything that's going on"
Calling employees cost,
production cost,
cost of goods sold,
market,
you need to know the numbers.
So, it goes back to the fact
if you want to lead, you have to do.
And if you don't do, you can't lead.
So, understand your business.
The other thing is, it's all about
leadership, motivation and morale
and how you communicate to people.
You're in the business of,
you may wanna be liked,
but you need to be respected.
And people will respect you
if you tell them the truth,
if you tell them what's going on,
if you set reasonable goals.
Okay.
The other thing is,
is you need to learn how to sell up
meaning if I'm the VP
of finance or marketing,
I'm gonna sell up to you
about what's going on.
I wanna anticipate
what's happening.
Right.
You need to manage your board
because your board may not be managing you
because they got
10 other deals going on.
Right.
So, the first time you get a glitch,
I need help.
It takes a strong person
to say, "I need help."
What do I do?
What do you think?
Nobody's gonna question your ability.
I mean, after the third time you do it,
I may fire you.
But the first and second time,
I'm gonna give you enough rope.
Sure. Sure.
So, I mean, it sounds to me that
it all comes back then
to integrity and honesty
and being open and allowing myself
to hold myself accountable,
but also allowing others
to hold me accountable.
But it sounds like
unless you've gone through
these crises yourself,
it's really, really hard
to empathize with them
and to really understand.
Because I can see in the future,
three years down the line,
I go to my board meeting
and something doesn't work
exactly like I think.
A board meeting is an hour long.
We do it once a month.
I'm gonna come in and I have nine other
incredible things I wanna say
that are just gonna help me
get my next round of investments
and gonna get me the next high five.
It's gonna take a lot of social,
a lot of personal responsibility
to get to say that one thing
that's not so nice. Right?
Look, I said it's about ethics,
integrity and leadership.
Those are the three words
you want me to end with.
I'm beginning with it.
I'm in the middle, I'm gonna end
with those same words.
I love it.
It's your responsibility to understand
how to sell and communicate. Okay
Now, because you're
the young entrepreneur,
you're gonna screw up
a couple times.
You have to.
But let me go back to the fact,
if you haven't done, you can't lead.
So, you can't, if you don't know
the financial numbers
or you don't know your gross margin
or you don't know the architecture,
resale, or the lead time to sell,
lead time to install,
lead time to close the sale,
lead time to get cash.
What your AR is
30 days, 45 days.
What's going on in payables.
What's going down
on the manufacturing floor.
You're in trouble. All right.
So, in good times,
everybody's having a ball.
Okay
And I've lived through now,
'87 to '89, '94 to '95,
'01 to '03, '07 to '10.
'12 to '14.
You know, this is different.
2020.
Why is this different? Why is this different?
Because it's the magnitude
where people are frozen
and they don't know what to do
meaning I have five proposals
out there right now.
I get calls from banks and equity.
And everybody has a leap of faith.
Hope that they shouldn't.
You have to,
I've always learned
that we're the last ones in
and everybody has that hope,
and you just play it out
and you bleed some more.
This cycle is very emotional.
And you sit here,
three months ago,
my partners and I discussed
the travel business,
the entertainment business,
the market coming back.
There's no way,
and we're now two and a half months later,
everybody thought it'd be great.
No way it's gonna happen.
It's gonna take a lot longer.
So, I encourage people to make
all the hard decisions now.
And I'll give you a different example.
Example is,
you have a prohibitive real estate lease.
You're a company that's doing revenue.
And you have, and this is an actual company,
it has 50 million bucks in the bank.
They're burning 10 million bucks a month.
They are gonna downsize,
but they have a contingent liability
of a real estate lease.
We've terminated and restructured about
$800 million of these problem
real estate leases.
$800 million. Wow.
What we tell people to do
is don't pay the rent.
Okay.
Go to the landlord and say,
"Hey, we need some help here."
And to the extent
that when we do this stuff
we gotta work something out.
And the landlord's gonna say,
"No. Pay the rent.
I'm gonna have my lawyer call you
and give you default"
And you're gonna say,
"I'm not gonna pay."
And that's going to cause
the landlord to do something.
Start spending money on lawyers,
creating havoc, etc.
And you're gonna sit there and say,
"We gotta negotiate."
Now where we were in '04 to '06,
this is the same timeline.
And I'll tell you the ultimate reason
why you do this, is that it took 18 months
to get before the courts then.
And basically, the worse you are,
the more leverage you have.
So, you do a contingent liability
liquidation analysis.
You show how bad it is.
And the worse you are,
you have more leverage.
You're playing poker.
You play the insolvency card.
All a landlord would get in an insolvency
is 12 months or 15% of the lease.
They may have two to four months
of letter accredited deposit.
You negotiate.
Because the problem is
they don't wanna wait that long
and you got time on your side here
Right.
Now the reason why you gotta do this
and I've had a number of companies
who should be doing it now
is five months from now
when you had that leap of faith
and you gotta go and raise
another 20 million,
you have this overhang
on your balance sheet.
And I'm gonna say,
"I'm not gonna give you 10 million bucks
when you got to 10 to $20 million
contingent liability out there"
Exactly.
So, a little different twist,
but it's all in the mental set
of how you run your business,
how you expect things to happen
and what happens going forward.
It sounds like more than anything,
you're coming in and you've seen
109 of these deals.
You have to come in with such resilience
and confidence that
because I mean, I'm assuming also that
the clients that are coming to you,
they're not in their happy state.
This is not a fun thing to do
that they're coming to you
to help when they're losing. Right?
So, you're sort of coming in
as their savior as sort
of like their -
Well, I woouldn't say their savior.
I'm coming in to maximize value.
We didn't create the problem,
we fix it, okay.
And you're not gonna call me,
if you call me as a CEO,
I'd take your call, I'd listen, etc.
But the only way you're gonna get to me
is the board told you to call me,
or the bank told you to call me.
All right.
And I'm gonna have credibility and say,
"Okay. Here's what the plan is.
And we're hired guns. We'll go in.
You gotta write a check to us like everybody else.
But we're the doctor on call"
So, interesting analogy.
I had, one of the proposals out is to a,
it's about $80 million invested
in a cancer development drug,
which is looking real good.
And they're out of money.
So, one of the board members
is a very high-profile surgeon.
So, he says to me,
"Well Steve, ... gotta do this
on a contingency. We'll help you out.
You'll make more in the back end."
I said, "No"
Look, I didn't create it.
We're here to fix it.
I'm the doctor on call.
If I go to you and say or you go to me and say,
"Okay, Steve, we're gonna
do some cancer surgery."
And I'm going to say,
"Okay, I only want to do something
and pay you if you do a good job"
You know whatever
So, we like the lawyers
and the other hired guns,
are cost of doing business.
So, our job is to make sure
we get the best value.
Move on.
And what happens in these cases
is that the creditors are able to at least
go through and hopefully work
with the new company.
The customers that are there
will be able to maintain
a flow that's in their system.
So, that's what we do.
Very very cool.
I mean, it's just a whole different world
that I had no idea   even existed.
And I mean, I'm sure that,
you have 109 different stories.
You shared a few here.
But I like you, the ones you shared, you have 109 more
than we didn't get to hear.
Steven, I need three words
that best describe you.
I already know what they are,
but I wanna hear it one more time.
Ethics, integrity, and leadership.
I love it.
Steven, thank you for the inspiration.
Toda raba and have a wonderful day.
Okay. You too buddy. You be well.
Thank you.